[Musique]
ils sont partout ils parlent de tout et
de rien ils souillent ils polluent et
embellissent la vie ils sont aimé
détester les graffitis sont sans cesse
source de polémique des patients de
refus de rejet
cet homme à l'alluré insignifiante à la
mine patibulaire regard sournois est un
chasseur un chasseur pas comme les
autres c'est un chasseur de graffitis le
mgm j'ai dit non non ça fait sûrement
pas pour moi je fais partie du hem j'ai
eu le mouvement les graffitis utile et
je cherche à savoir ce que peut être le
mg ou le mj vous savez ce que c'est le
mgm génie ça veut dire quoi une vie un
jour sans on ne savait pas inutile
inutile mouvement les graffitis inutile
vous croyez
est ce que vous lisez les graffitis dans
le métro bondé moi je les lis tous et
les caisses que tu lis comme graffitis
je lis surtout faire attention surtout
attirés par les messages revendicatifs
vol et détournement d'image m'intéresse
me font rire mais je les regarde moins
attirés par les les graffitis qui troque
qui transporte un message est ce que tu
fais des graffitis
j'ai fait une fois des graffitis sts
dans les wc parce que quand j'étais seul
s'était caché on les voyait baume et
j'étais un peu plus libres pour pouvoir
écrire sur un mur et d'autre part j'en
avais déjà sur le mur donc c'était pas
comme si je chauffe en sait quelque
chose que déjà kaka avait pris le droit
de le faire donc je n'avais plus qu'à
répondre mieux privilégier de
l'expression graphite
l'université est là l'inquiétant
chasseurs de graffitis s'en donnent à
coeur joie
[Musique]
ce que j'ai appris au cours havrais je
prends mon marqueur et je remarque sur
les murs mais légèrement différent nota
peser les pour
sur les murs de la faculté ou à la rue
alors maintenant vous pouvez faire votre
émission passé sur les murs et regardez
ce qu'a marqué et vous comprendrez ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur des classes
[Musique]
et
par rapport aux graffitis qui dans ce
sens si par exemple ils ont perdu tout à
fait leur sens aux victimes
ils transmettent absolument rien c'est
pas la liberté d'expression ses soeurs
de peindre les murs c'est un problème
c'est que c'est absolument inesthétiques
et c'est absolument affreux bon
promenez-vous dans toutes les facultés
vous verrez des graffitis de toutes
tendances politiques confondues et
graffitis sur n'importe quoi s'est passé
à la liberté d'expression est ce que
vous faites des graffitis oui c'est
grave aussi d'amour entre les nouveaux
[Musique]
et pendant ce temps là le chasseur de
graffitis et chasse
la fièvre du graffiti n'épargne aucune
partie du monde
aux états unis elles se confondent avec
des peintures murales comme en témoigne
le film d'agnès varda murmure un paradis
pour le chasseur de graffitis
on
cela
[Musique]
agnès varda
vous avez observé des graffitis aux
états unis quelle différence vous fait
avec ce qu'on peut rencontrer en france
et notamment dans le métro
le français écrit des choses pour
français une seule et vivait en france
écrit des phrases le graphique américain
n'est pas les phrases plupart du temps
ce sont des mots quelquefois des slogans
je n'ai jamais vu ces longues phrases
qu'on voit ici face nous ont commencé
quand même en 68 des phrases
extraordinaire on lisait sur les murs et
les phrases drôles comme eux il est
interdit d'interdire et toutes ces
choses là
c'est particulièrement politique ne se
trouve pas en amérique à mon avis
et pendant ce temps là le patibulaire
chasseurs de graffitis chasse
parce que votre avis il faut ou pas en
france tolérer le graffiti est aussi
dans le métro je crois que c'est
essentiel de tolérer graffiti avec si
vous voulez dans une double position
c'est à dire maintenant tolérer
permettant de nettoyer répondez vous aux
gens qui disent les graffitis ça swing
les murs ça pollue la cité il faut les
interdire ça les jeunes qu'ils ont peur
d'être gênés ils ont peur de tout ce qui
est trop cru ils ont peur de tout ce
qu'ils trouveraient je suis frappé comme
il ya beaucoup plus de raffi petits
cochons pour accéder enfin
particulièrement dans le cabinet de sas
ans n existe pas en amérique
et pendant ce temps-là l'obsédante
affaires de graffitis pour vous
étudiants des beaux-arts qu'est ce que
c'est et graffitis toujours fait partie
de l'environnement de l'école j'ai
toujours vu depuis qu'on à l'école on le
voit est vraiment parti d'un paysage en
fait d'une marque d'un décor d'accord
c'est toute une série de
deux moments qui sont sans transposer un
témoignage de passage d'étudiants four
[Musique]
et pendant ce temps-là deviner
cambrai pourquoi notre chasseur relève
t-il avec autant de soin des graffitis
et il est noble historiens artistes
il trouve qu'il n'a malgré leur pauvreté
d'imagination une source d'inspiration
bah pourquoi pas
ce n'est pas un musée d'oeuvres d'art ce
ne sont pas des oeuvres originales mais
en fait des copies en plâtre qui
représente toute une imagerie pour lever
autour des négligés dans les cachots et
que je souhaite conserver je souhaite
protéger maintenant de la destruction
ce qui fait que j'ai eu l'idée de créer
ce musée là il ya deux ans à peu près
minutes de marseille
[Musique]
le fait que les graffitis anciens sont
essentiellement des images et les
modernes démo commence que l'expliqué et
bien parce que dans les époques
médiévale jusqu'à la renaissance même
après les individus n'avaient pas
instructions permettant justement de
décrire et la formation se faisaient
bien sûr parle par l'image
marie ange viendrez vous fait une thèse
sur les graffitis vous n'avez pas
l'impression que ça fait pas très
sérieux cette question là ne se pose pas
aux états unis puisqu'elle a fait
l'objet de nombreuses communications
dans les revues scientifiques qui a même
un enseignement du rafidia new york dans
l'université de new york
le graffiti existe presque autant que
l'homme c'est à dire qu'on l'a vu
apparaître la première fois dans les
grottes du paléolithique steria 30
millions c'est d'abord essentiellement
l'histoire des gens sans histoire c'est
à dire de ceux qui n'ont pas laissé
trans et qui a par le graffiti
n'existerait plus dans la mémoire des
prisons d'hier à celle d'aujourd'hui
[Rires]
oublié aujourd'hui et songe à demain
liberté dont crimes et laisse ton
chagrin ton corps est en cash dont
claire dans les points
oublie donc d'arracher songe à demain
plusieurs fois en prison est ce que vous
avez graphite et j'ai toujours gravité
mais le véritable graffiti c'est au
dépôt que j'ai pratiqué véritablement le
graffiti et parce que au dépôt c'est
l'endroit où l'on est dans l'angoissé
totale le graffiti correspond à un
besoin d'expression tout c'est la seule
expression que l'on a je m'appelle
yvelines j'ai 17 ans et demi
maman pourquoi m'as tu abandonné ici je
t'en veux pas ton enfant chéri
annick 15 ans
prends mon mal en patience et ne maudit
point impose à ton coeur le silence
celui qui est au dépôt il graphite avec
des morceaux de moins arracher du banc
soit avec un crayon qui la gamme eee pc
l'habitude de venir au dépôt et à et
c'est c'est la seule et la seule
expression possible pour l'individu et
ses correspond un soulagement de dalheim
libération totale
[Musique]
moi aussi j'ai 15 ans j'ai déjà un
enfant de quatre mois
ils nous ont enlevés autonome tombé à la
manif du 24 novembre 79 frappé un crs et
un flic en civil avec une barre de fer
demain flory
oui
des lieux où vous pourriez graphite est
ce que ce sera encore des graffitis ce
que vous vivriez de la même façon la
caractéristique essentielle du graffiti
c'est justement que c'est interdit et
que c'est voué à la disparition de toute
manière il ya quand même cette espèce de
plaisir un peu malsain à contrer le
l'interdît et c'est françois que s'il y
avait des lieux libéralisé et c'est ça
de s'asseoir encore le graffiti ça
serait encore un moyen d'expression mais
s'estime plus pour ce qu'on appelle le
graffiti
[Musique]
mais pendant ce temps là l'obsédé jubile
da
[Musique]
oui
de plus en plus on n'avait qu'à regarder
autour de vous la fièvre graffitis qui
s'empare du tout le monde
[Musique]